today we formally adopt it at the
directive on automatic exchange of
information between the member states of
the European Union we discussed the
common consolidated corporate tax base
directive the European Commission is
going to present a full package on
transparency and on taxation in January
and we were also able to agree on how we
would need to strengthen and enhance the
code of conduct of the European Union in
two months we've been able to shape a
general approach on the directive
dedicated to securitisation so that we
can move very quickly on this item which
is the first milestone in the capital
markets Union we've also agreed today on
bridge financing for the single
resolution find this bridge financing
will start to function on the first of
January 2016 which is the goal that we
had so this aspect of the banking Union
is also functioning ministers agreed to
work on fighting terrorism financing as
a absolute priority the Commission today
set out options this includes working
hard to trace financing sources such as
illicit movements of cash increasingly
through systems that allow virtual
currencies to be exchanged for real
money anonymously extra checks on the
purchase and distribution of prepaid
cards more will grant registering of
bank accounts and freezing assets better
information sharing of financial
intelligence ministers of ten member
states have just agreed in principle on
key parameters of a financial
transaction tax for participating member
states the remaining details will be
worked out by the participating
mistakes before the summer